I'm marki the MooMoo tribe you're not
with me then you're wrong
oh there we go mark in the MooMoo Oh God
not that music Jesus alright anyway
working the movers on the server no one
eat me okay up hello hi okay got it over
again
been a while been a little while since I
played agario anyone want to help out
marking the movie anyway
anybody want to help anyone to help out
and oh no don't need marking the MooMoo
the [ __ ] in the movie who didn't do
nothing you won't you do anything to
mark him in the MooMoo stupid music okay
alright
I've totally forgotten what the controls
actually are so I have no idea
murder thank you thank you you're
sacrificing we went to a great cause
I've actually I've legitimately
forgotten what all the cool I think
space is space dude oh oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no okay for fun hello Makka Moo
hello thank you oh god oh god oh god oh
god
some people find Marky the movement who
please how about Mike is MooMoo the
Margay moo moo moo needs so much help
the mark in the movie was so scared I
thought this game does this game just
makes me scared it's so heart racing I I
need to play more of this on the channel
I really want to play more of this but
soon soon I'll get to it I think our is
launch spaces faces hello
oh thank you oh my gosh thank you oh my
gosh you're the best
oh wait my big enough I should turn on
like the the things where I can see
their numbers that way I would
definitely know if I could meet one or
not
oh it's nice having friends having
friends is the best awesome
it's so much better than their going it
alone and everyone just hating me eating
me up I wash - thank you thank you
tomorrow
marking the movie appreciation your
sacrifices oh my gosh get away from
worse - don't you dare don't you try it
use my bro
get away from my bro you guys oh oh my
god also it love so but love oh that's
not love that's hate let's concentrate
oh so nice I'm having so much fun oh
thank you thank you very much oh my gosh
this is the greatest thing Marcus my
life hello you want to join in to me you
want to become part of my life thank you
thank you
Marky the movies here this is so cool
Thank You bucks - thank you ah hi hello
hello everybody
you guys are soaked I'm like my heart is
so warmed up right now I'm so happy this
is so cool this is the coolest literally
the coolest thank you oh my gosh you
guys are so nice thank you
oh my gosh it's so days I got you oh
look at that
what you got a poker face there I'll
come over here
what come over here hey it's markiplier
backwards mmm I have totally forgotten
what the the eating button is oh he'll
space okay no space I got it and then W
was shooting that was right thank you
oh my gosh there's some nice this is
what it's like to cheat this is so
cheating but it's so so much fun this is
why people do youtubers I got to number
two by myself with people working
against me so I'm not too upset about
anyone you
giving me the sauce here hello look it's
so scary the hell is that
anybody else want to help me I think all
of my helper helper tins have been
giving me too much so they don't have
anything left
oh my god what is that Jesus ah okay all
right we got a thank you okay now I'm
one singular piece all right so now if
my guys are still gonna be super cool to
me which they are and have been thank
you
all right hi Ted Cruz ah I don't want to
make any moves just in case someone
trying to help me up
oh that's not more than two fake
marquita MooMoo that's a fakie
you're not marking the MooMoo I'm
marking the MooMoo I'm marking the
MooMoo number eight yeah
Oh Kelis is coming he'll be help Oh mark
in the man woman's head in trouble
Margot MooMoo he's help he'll Mergui the
MooMoo somebody help marki the bamboo oh
my god someone please anybody help mark
in the move move anyway assistance
please assistance eat it for Marquis
move move we're gonna move move Elise is
eating me whoa whoa this could be the
end Rebecca tell you bugs am help help
help
thank you thank you very much a little
more thank you thank you Oh God
with that other mark in the movie
looking in being a dick bag trying to
get me eating what about da poopy oh god
he's still trying to eat me he's still
trying to eat me he's still got a me
thank you
oh god no oh god no hello okay so now he
can't eat me I'm pretty sure oh man I
was so scary it was Gary
thank you you think he thank you thank
you thank you strum Bonilla oh straw
baloney
Oh strong baloney Oh Strahm baloney
okay for Margie mu so fun so oh man it's
totally unfair it's completely unfair
what's going on here but still still a
free cool
I feel so greedy cuz I'm not giving to
anyone else but you know why would I
Marky's moo moo I'll defend semaine
market the moo moo defend the ranch brew
become one with market moo moo become am
one with market moo moo ah those low
he'll be he'll bargain the moo moo ah
come on eat ruh-roh
I almost don't know what to do anymore
because I'm gone hey cool oh my god Alou
is on my team
oh thank you thank you thank you
ah I'd still eat you if I had the chance
but thank you ah thank you
I'm sorry all my loyal people that I
just ate up like a dick I'm so sorry uh
look sorry
who's is the opportunity was there why
would I have I'm not going for you a lo
you're you're cool you're cool in my
book you're cool a low you're cool I
don't know how I'm gonna end this I know
I'm gonna somehow screw this up so all I
can imagine is that somehow someway I'm
gonna do some douchey and screw-up look
I'm big now I am now big
hello this seems opportunistic I kind of
want to take advantage of our 10,000
mess oh my god
thank you hi mark Thank You scepter
plier thank you mark wants mass you guys
are the best
you guys are like the best you guys are
the best there ever was I've never felt
so number one before in my life I've
never felt so much good boy you guys are
the best
why you're so nice to me you
oh you almost got as big as me how did
he get as almost as big as me over here
by himself
the marquee of the murmurers attention
has been turned on you I need more I
need more mass I need more mass t this
guy everyone give me your mass give me
all of your mass it's time to do a
little duel
like I'm gonna be able to get through
that ah he's gonna slip away what a dick
back oh he was not oh he popped Wow oh
there are I pop what did I pop what did
I hit I have no idea what I hit I really
have no idea what I hit ah crap feel it
like I'm gonna pop I'm gonna pop it all
up pop it all up work work in the MooMoo
generous Joule fall
look at Margita movement giving away to
all his friends I'm just gonna pop
myself as much as I can here cuz I kind
of want to start over because I've kind
of won this so much that there's almost
no point in continuing so might as well
just start blowing myself up yes
tato your time has come except not
really because I'm gonna give all my
mass to other people eat eat my [ __ ]
eat least one my body freeze on my body
oh this longer the winner it is more Oh